- Here's the problem
is that when you...
It's not so much sales but
brainwashing that was going on.
And when you're
brainwashing people
or trying to create a certain
culture or a thought culture,
there's these two sides to it.
It's, number one, the constant
reinforcement of one message.
It's a constant reinforcement
bombarding a message:
"Danger, danger,
death, death, death.
You stay home. Stop everything.
World has changed," right?
But there's another
side to it, too.
You have to squash all
other competing messages,
and that's where the
platforms came in,
and they literally
stopped free speech,
and they made it so you
could only hear one message,
and that brainwashed people.
(tranquil music)
- All right, people, our
first live in-studio...
In-house? What're
we calling this?
Shoot with the original Wolf
of Wall Street, Jordan Belfort.
- What's up.
- My friend, who also
fled Los Angeles,
and we are here living the
life in Miami, Florida.
You look like Miami.
Well, you got the black
shirt, so that's a little L.A.
But the tan, you look
like a million bucks.
You just told me
you're 59 years old.
- I know. Can I
tell you something.
- What's going on here?
- But it's an interesting
type of fleeing, ya know?
We come from Long Island.
And they fled from the
Bronx out to Long Island.
This is a fleeing back,
cross-country fleeing, ya know?
Fleeing I don't know what.
Is it a combination of
taxes, bad government,
crime due to prosecutors not
arresting for petty thefts.
I don't know.
Like I said, you're
in New Yorker, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I remember when...
It was so bad when I grew up
that you went to Times Square,
you would just never come home.
Good chance you were
getting killed, right?
- Drugs and sex
shops. That's it.
- It was a time when you
had a death wish to move in
back then, right?
- Yeah. (laughs) Yes.
- And then some guy named
Rudy Giuliani came in.
You can hate him
or love the guy,
but what he did was he just
had this zero-tolerance policy
on lifestyle crimes.
Squeegee people, arrested.
Any petty got arrested.
And you know what
happened? It trickled up.
And murder rate plummeted.
Violent crime plummeted.
It was really interesting.
Police presence soared.
(thuds) So gee, what a shock.
Defund the police,
and look what happens.
- And now they're
literally doing the reverse
where the petty
crimes are the ones
they're letting you off on.
Jump the turnstile.
You're good to go.
Steal some stuff outta
CVS. You're good to go.
- That's the root of...
I saw it.
I'll never forget it,
'cause it was like,
"Aw, that's so terrible
he's arresting the
squeegee (indistinct)."
And you watched. It miraculously
cleaned up the city.
It was amazing, ya know?
- So, when I called you, I
think, second week in December,
or I texted you, just to
say, "Hey, I moved to Miami"
and then you respond
a minute later,
you're like, "I moved to Miami."
I had no idea you were moving.
You didn't know I was moving.
I got out real quick.
I was just like, "I
gotta get outta here."
How long did it take
you to figure out
that Cali just wasn't working
or L.A. wasn't working?
We had talked about it a
little bit about a year ago,
but where you lived...
I was a little more off the
beaten path in the Valley.
You lived in a super-nice
area in the Hills,
but right below that-
- A friend of mine
who owns a huge...
Fashion Nova.
Rich, Fashion Nova,
he lives about, maybe,
quarter-mile from me.
He got followed home
in the Hills there,
and there was a shootout.
They shot his bodyguard,
and his bodyguard killed
one of the people.
And this is happening once...
I don't know how...
I don't wanna exaggerate,
but it's happening
frequently enough-
- Oh yeah, I was hearing
gunshots in Encino.
- That you just
can't wear a watch.
My wife's from Argentina.
She's like, "When you
go to Buenos Aires,
don't wear a watch."
She's like, "Oh
yeah, L.A., too, now.
(both laughs)
- Was that it for you?
Were there a couple
things, like the taxes?
Obviously, you're a money guy.
- Taxes weren't good there.
We'll talk about some
of that kinda stuff.
You love success.
That's your whole thing.
You love that more than anybody.
Was that driving ya nuts?
Or were you willing to...
Everyone in L.A.'s willing
to do it for a while.
- I was for a while.
I don't mind paying taxes,
but I do mind if they're
not using the money wisely.
They're wasting the money.
That kinda bothers me
if they're using it for
things I don't agree with.
But to me, it was a combination
of, number one, when
Trump changed the law
that didn't allow you to
write off your state taxes
against your federal.
That was a big hit for
someone like myself
and a lotta people.
That was one thing.
I didn't agree with
that, but hey, whatever.
Can't agree with everyone
on policies, right.
But it was a combination
of the taxes, the lifestyle,
and, also, the politics.
Listen, I'm probably
very much like you,
conservative fiscally, socially
liberal as you can get.
That's me, basically,
in a nutshell.
But I felt like it was almost
this weird virtue signaling.
How low can you go on the
virtue signaling continuum?
It's uncomfortable. I don't
wanna live amongst that stuff.
And then when COVID hit,
I came down to Florida,
and it was like, "Free
at last. Free," right?
- Were you shocked?
Every day that I've been here,
I'm like, "Man, I
can't believe it.
I feel like I'm waking
up in a dream every day."
- I'm gonna tell ya.
I got in some trouble on...
What was it?
Instagram and YouTube.
I got my stuff taken
down for saying
that lockdowns don't work.
- What'd you do?
But they proved it.
- What are you? Anti-science?
- I know, right?
I was saying things
that's just my opinion.
I'm like, "I think
that you're locking
down the wrong people.
I think we should
lock down older people
who really would get affected
and let the people who are
healthy go out and work.
And all the money
that we're gonna save,
we can take the old
people, give 'em caviar
and filet mignon and Champagne
the rest of their lives.
You know what I'm saying?
Take care of the older people,
but protect them instead of
just locking everyone down,
causing economic chaos.
And it didn't work anyway.
The greatest thing, honestly,
was Omicron, the last one,
because it was so infectious
that everyone just got it,
so it was natural herd immunity.
And that was really, I think,
what ended this pandemic
more than anything else
was that Omicron
was so contagious.
I was in Punta del Este,
Uruguay, for New Year's.
I think the whole...
(laughs) Everybody in
the whole area had it.
That's how contagious it was.
But people weren't
really dying from it.
And it was, at least I think,
the best end you
could've had to...
Hopefully, it's the end.
But to what was, to
me, almost like...
How'd I say it?
It was almost like
a Kafka-esque series
of actions by world
governments to do...
I'm not sure even what
they were trying to do.
- But do you think it's over?
To me, act two is coming.
- Fauci's just dying.
He just can't wait.
Fauci's praying that.
- Urgh.
- Listen, I think
that you never know.
The difference with COVID...
And in the beginning, listen,
it coulda been the Spanish flu.
But it wasn't.
I don't know why they
couldn't accept that.
It wasn't the Spanish flu.
The Spanish flu was a
very different thing,
when people would
literally, you or I,
in the prime just drop dead.
- [Dave] That's it, yeah.
- It was very different.
This was something that
was in a different level,
but it was almost like there
was like this weird global...
I don't know if
it's a conspiracy.
It's like the madness
is contagious,
almost like this mass
delusion that was happening.
And I still don't know why.
I really don't understand it,
'cause it never
made sense to me.
Why? Okay, I get it.
It's a real virus.
People are getting sick, right?
Some people are very,
very susceptible,
but like when you
looked at it logically,
it just wasn't making any sense,
loved one's being locked down.
I don't know. The
counter on the screen?
What the fuck?
- (laughs) You don't
strike me as the type
that would lock down very well.
- Pfft, please.
- You need people, right?
You really need people.
- My wife, she was ready to
kill me 'cause she's like...
You know her. She's
law-abiding citizen.
She's listening to the news.
Her English wasn't
perfect back then.
All she's seeing is "death,
death, death, death,
lockdown, lockdown, right?
And I'm like...
People are coming over, hugging.
She's like, "What
are you doing?"
I'm like, "Listen, you're gonna
kill me from disinfectant."
She's disinfecting the food,
spraying the fricking
things with fucking ammonia.
I'm like, "I'm gonna die
of ammonia poisoning,
not from COVID," right?
So she was really careful,
and I was just not.
I literally went out, and I
said, "You know what? Fuck it."
I'd rather just get it.
I wanted to get it
because as I wanted to
become immune to it.
And that's what happened,
by the way, is I got it,
and I was sick for
a couple of days.
I have a very strong immune
system, and I got sick.
I have nothing that
would ever give me a...
I have nothing. I
have a strong heart.
I'm not about overweight.
I have the right blood type.
So it was like,
"Hey, lemme get it."
I got it. I was sick for a
couple days, nothing bad.
Then I got it a second time,
and I only tested
positive and no symptoms.
Then since then, I've literally
walked into COVID wards,
and I can't catch
it anymore, ya know?
So I mean, yeah.
- Not that I want to give
these freaks any ideas,
but when they
bring COVID back...
I just know they're
bringing it back.
Did they screw up
something in the sales job?
Because after the
two-weeks-to-flatten-the-curve
thing,
I kinda realized it
was all nonsense.
I knew the old world
wasn't coming back.
I didn't believe them.
I didn't believe the body
language, the messaging,
the commercials,
everything based on fear.
Should they have done
something different sale...
What should we watch
out for, I guess,
is what I'm asking you.
- Here's the problem
is that when you...
It's not so much sales but
brainwashing that was going on.
And when you're
brainwashing people
or trying to create a certain
culture, a thought culture,
there's these two sides to it.
It's, number one, the constant
reinforcement of one message.
It's a constant reinforcement
bombarding a message:
"Danger, danger,
death, death, death.
You stay home. Stop everything.
World has changed," right?
But there's another
side to it, too.
You have to squash all
other competing messages.
And that's where the
platforms came in,
and they literally
stopped free speech,
and they made it so you
could only hear one message,
and that brainwashed people.
But even that, I
think, there was...
Listen, there was many people
who almost had no choice.
The society just...
They virtue signaled us to
be rational people to death.
But it was like,
"You actually
believe this shit?"
It was ridiculous.
Am I gonna believe my eyes
or the nonsense I'm
hearing in the press?
By the way, it's still going
on right now with other things.
I have literally...
It just shocks me,
the lack of legitimacy
on TV with the news.
- What do we do? What
do we do about it?
That literally what my show-
Let's go with Ukraine.
I think what Putin
do was terrible,
but there's more than one
side to the story, for sure.
And that's awful.
Doesn't mean that he shouldn't
be thought of as a bad guy
for invading a country,
but it's just like...
I don't know.
- Oh, so you're a
Putin apologist.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Is that it, Belfort?
- I'm a Putin apologist.
- Yeah.
- You said something
with nuance.
- I know.
- What're you? Nuts?
- But I saw a really
interesting interview on Tucker.
And I knew that before.
I had been thinking
this all along.
And I didn't say it
this time. You know why?
Because it is a very
difficult tightrope to walk,
because it's not
my responsibility.
I'm not that guy.
That's not who I am.
I'm not here to bring
the news to the world.
But if I was, I certainly
would speak my mind more.
But people are
dying. It's awful.
It's fucking awful, what's
going on there, right?
But that being said, it
is not black and white,
and this guy's Zelenskyy
is no fricking...
He's no stellar person
that represents democracy.
- He just banned 11
political parties,
lefty political parties.
- In the name of democracy?
- But why isn't the
news talking about this?
- I think 'cause they
wanna do it here, too.
And they're just
running the test game.
I know that all
sounds nuts, but...
Well, that that's a good one.
Is there anything
that I could say
or anything that you would hear
that you'd be like, "Nah,
that can't be right."
Everything is so
outta whack right now
that you'd believe anything.
- This seems pretty obvious.
This is the
military-industrial complex
doing what they do best:
war, weapons, destruction.
This guy's Zelenskyy is saying
we're on the verge
of World War III.
Over Ukraine?
- Yeah, what?
- It's not even a
strategic point for us.
Why is Ukraine...
What about what's going
on in Syria or Yemen?
There's all these other
slaughters around the world.
Or what we did to
Iraq or Afghanistan...
Why is this suddenly...
Why are we supposed to go to war
and start World War
III over Ukraine?
As bad as I think what's
happening in Ukraine...
I'm not saying
it's not terrible.
And I'm sympathetic
to the people.
And I've been to Ukraine many
times now, amazing people.
But I'm not interested
in starting World
War III over this.
- What do you make
of how they change the
messaging so quickly?
The State of the Union,
Biden does a half hour
on Ukraine to start
as he's standing there with
no masks, Pelosi behind him.
She's 900. He's 800.
The average American
is not walking around
thinking about
Ukraine that often.
And again, that's not
diminishing what's
going on there,
and you can't just invade
a sovereign nation,
but how do they...
The messaging of
how they flip it,
they flip it so quickly
to get everybody's
eye on something else.
- It's shocking.
It's really shocking.
And I think that the
most shocking part
is it was probably
always like this.
It's just that we
live in a world now
where it's very hard to not
have things be transparent.
The manipulation
was always there.
We always say, "Oh, I long
for the days of Walter."
He was probably just
as bad, ya know?
(Dave chuckles)
So I think that right now,
it's really hard
to hide anything.
So you have these
more discerning minds
that are just
saying, "Bullshit."
They call bullshit.
And I think those minds
were out there before
but they had nowhere
to call bullshit.
You have social media
about, the platforms
where people can have voices.
So the dissenting at least
gets out there somewhat
before it's squashed (laughs).
- It's so funny 'cause we've
done each other's shows
a bunch of times before.
When I've had you over
for dinner or whatever,
we can do the politics thing.
And it's funny to me that you
sort of talk about politics
but if you never talk
about politics again,
you'd be fine, right?
- I don't really...
Listen, I'm very
much into politics,
but it's not where I...
My heartbeat is not in politics.
It intrigues me in the sense
that it's the most corrupt,
shockingly corrupt, institution.
What's happened is is that the
press and the attack squads
have created a paradigm
where no one that really
has anything good going
would wanna run for office.
Trump, I couldn't
believe he did it.
Maybe he didn't realize what
he was getting himself into,
but why would you
run for office?
It's just the most
evil thing that...
They dig up any dirt that
you have. They just try to...
It's all about undermining you,
tripping you up,
discrediting you.
It's shocking.
It's like almost like the
Gestapo is on both sides
just trying to destroy,
destroy, propaganda.
And it's not about truth,
and it's not about making
the country a better place.
I really think that the U.S.
has seen its better days
and ain't coming back.
I don't think so.
- So, do you see way outta this?
To me, I see that
there'll be pockets out,
where we are right now.
Miami is the future.
Florida is the future.
I think there's a base there
and all the people moving
and they get it, why
they're moving here.
Techs moving here.
I think there's a
bullish attitude here,
but I think a lot of it is gone.
Do you think it's
gone altogether?
Or it's just gonna
slowly disintegrate?
- Lemme restate
that, what I mean.
What happens is rich people,
not just the rich rich
but people that know
how to make money,
they're always gonna make money,
and they're always
gonna live good lives.
They're survivors.
People that are
gonna be really poor
are always gonna be dirt poor
'cause they have
dirt-poor mentality.
They don't wanna do anything
to get themselves outta poverty.
But then there's all
these other people
that really work hard
in the middle class.
Those are the ones that are
getting squeezed the most.
Those people having the
American dream robbed from them.
So to me, it doesn't
matter to me at all.
You're always gonna
make a lotta money.
You're at that point
where, oh, you make a little
bit loss, doesn't matter.
You get the life you want.
But I think what happens is
it's the people in the middle
that really, really suffer.
And the dollar
buys less and less.
Job opportunities are
becoming scarcer and scarcer.
And this wokeism, I
think, is the death
of so much liberty
in this country.
I look at this...
This classic meme is the
picture of this swimmer.
And it says it all.
You look at her.
She's seven feet tall,
and the little
girls are cowering.
And people just don't stop that?
The country has lost
its moral compass.
- She has a penis, by the way.
- She does?
- She has a penis.
- Oh, still.
- Yeah, she's still
got the penis.
So the girls in the
locker room are not happy,
because she walks around
and she's got a penis.
- Really?
- And we're saying she
'cause you're trying
to be respectful
at some level.
- It's a rudder, maybe,
for when she swims.
- (laughs) That's funny.
(Jordan laughs)
But you know what I mean?
You're trying to be respectful.
I know you. You are.
- What?
- So you're using the pronoun.
- It's not even that.
- But you're also
mocking the reality.
This is a big dude who, in
effect, is crushing these girls.
And the feminists.
(Dave applauds)
- Terrible.
Here's the thing, though.
- You have a daughter
around that age, right?
- Why do I call her she?
It's no skin off...
If she wants to be called
she, I'll call her she.
It doesn't bother me.
I don't care if Cecil...
If you wanna be called
she or a big fat galoot,
I'll call ya that, too.
I don't care what
you wanna be called.
I don't care about
labels like that.
So if that makes her happy,
that makes her happy.
I guess some people will
say, "No, she's a he"
and (indistinct)
refuse to do it.
I don't care. I'm sympathetic.
I want her to be
as happy as she can
or whatever you wanna
call her, right?
- But now it's at the
expense of those girls.
- But now this is just nonsense.
This is fucking pure nonsense.
And if you don't know that,
you're sick, you're crazy.
If you don't know that
that's patently unfair...
It's beyond obvious.
It's patently ridiculous.
How could this be allowed?
- Do you think anyone
really buys it?
Or they're just
all in on the mob
and they're all in
on the groupthink?
- Anyone that buys that
is fucking brain dead.
It's part of something
much darker and more evil,
to have that woman or man,
whatever you wanna say she is,
competing against women
that have worked
their whole lives
to get to this spot,
and one girl didn't
make the cut.
It's fucked up.
And there's no way...
It's just not fair.
I said this, by the way.
I came out and said this
on TikTok a long time ago.
Right when it first
started, I came out.
And by the way,
I was generally supported.
I got no hate on it.
The only hate, I think, I got
was from conservative people
because I said, "Listen,
I'm socially liberal."
I started saying,
"I'm very liberal."
But this is not about that.
This is a about fairness,
and this is just...
It's idiotic, and I
don't know why she would,
or he would.
It's an empty victory.
- Right, wait, so what were
the conservatives getting
on you for?
- "How could you say
you're socially liberal?"
- Oh, oh, oh, oh, got it.
- Well, 'cause I am.
I don't care who's fucking who.
What do I care?
Do I really give a
shit who fucks who?
Honestly, I don't
care about that stuff.
I say that I'm prejudiced
against two types of people,
lazy people and stupid people.
Everyone else I'm
okay with, ya know?
- Yeah, I wanna back up
to something you said it
before about the government,
'cause it was making me
think of Wolf of Wall Street.
The thing about the...
The movie's so
freaking brilliant.
I won't make you talk about it,
'cause you've talked about
it a bajillion times,
but you base...
You're the hero of
the movie, obviously,
and yet you're also
doing some illegal shit.
You're doing some immoral shit,
however you wanna describe it,
but ya hate the feds more.
Ya hate the people
going after you more,
and they're supposed to
be the good guys in this,
'cause you're doing stuff
with the penny stocks,
or whatever it is.
And that, I think, captures
what you said about
the government before.
They've done so much stuff now
that it's like "The Sopranos."
You're never rooting
against Tony.
He's killing people, and
you're still rooting for him.
Does that tell you something
about how backwards
everything is
in an odd way?
- Yeah, well, I think
that the lines of
right-and-wrong morality
have been very much blurred.
I think people just realize...
For example, my case
specifically, people know
that what I did was nothing
compared to what they did
in Goldman Sachs
and Merrill Lynch.
These guys bankrupted
Iceland and Greece
and almost took down the
entire world economy,
and no one went to jail.
At least I went to jail for a
couple years and did my time.
And I had to pay the price,
and I had to rebuild my life.
That was 1,000 times worse.
Doesn't mean what
I did was right.
But people also saw this...
I think people like, almost,
the tortured-soul type.
You're watching me
walk off the edge:
"Wait, stop. Don't do it."
People see there
was goodness in me.
There was misguidedness in me.
And I think people
like that complexity,
and you could root for someone
who, I think, you feel genuinely
they're almost their
own worst enemy.
They're not out killing
people, and even, by the way,
with Tony, (indistinct) Tony,
you can root for Tony, too.
But in this case, I'm
not killing people.
But you said, "Why? Why?"
And I think people
can see themselves
in a lot of the characters
in that type of movie.
And that's Scorsese's
brilliance, by the way.
He doesn't moralize.
He just puts characters up
that are actually
real and complex,
and you're watching good
people do bad things
or terrible people
do good things.
- When you look
back on all that...
Even when you post pictures
a lotta times on Instagram,
you'll post pictures of what
you were doing back then,
30 years ago, what you
were actually doing.
Are you like, "Man,
that was just freaking
great," even though...
How long were you in jail for?
- 22 months.
- All right, not terrible.
- And it wasn't
a terrible jail.
- Little more than Jussie
Smollett, but yeah.
- (chuckles) Jussie,
God Almighty, another
character, right?
Ya know, one thing I'll say
is that when I look
back at what happened,
the one thing I wish I
did less of was the drugs.
The drugs did not
enhance things.
They corrupted a lotta things,
and they made a lotta memories
really far less
enjoyable and colorful
than they shoulda been.
For example, I've fallen asleep
in the finest
restaurants in the world.
(Dave laughs)
I got booked for a speech
next month in Monaco, right?
And they got a beautiful suite
at the Hotel de Paris, right?
And I'm like, "Oh (claps)
yeah, I fell asleep
at the Louis XIV restaurant
in a bowl of soup.
It was a $12,000 dinner.
I can't remember it, but
I remember was 12 grand,
and my wife had
to pick my head up
outta the fricking soup," right?
So that was the
story of my life.
So that aspect, I
look back and say,
"I wish I could've done things
differently with the drugs."
But other than that,
when I look at it,
I wouldn't change anything,
because it was like what got
me to this point in my life.
Obviously, I made some mistakes.
I had a lotta fun, did a
lot of things right as well.
But I think looking back at
your life and trying to say,
"I shouldn't have done"...
I don't think that's healthy.
- What do you think kept
you going like that?
You're not broken now.
You're so thriving.
Every time I'm around you,
and everyone knows it,
you're infectious
with your energy.
This is exactly who
you are off camera.
You just freaking love life.
Did you ever get to a point
where you were starting to break
or anything like that?
- Yeah, yeah, of course I did.
I think that the worst part
was before I went to jail.
It's like you're
dying in slow motion.
And that's where
you know, you can't-
- 'Cause you know you're going.
- And you can't
restart your life.
I lived in the big house
still. They hadn't taken...
It's like the falling
empire of Rome.
You're watching the house
collapse or everything collapse
around me, right?
For me, the amount
of pride that I took
in rebuilding my life ethically,
I can't tell you what
that meant to me,
to go out and prove to myself,
to my children, not the
world, to my children,
that I would go out right again
and just do things so
straight as an arrow
and empower people
all over the world
and make even more money.
And that was something
that just kept me going
in the early days.
It just snowballed and fed
in itself and fed in itself.
Yeah, my life today is far
better than it ever was
back in the craziest
times of Stratton.
- Yeah, that's gotta
be a crazy retraining,
to try to do things
fully on the up and up.
We were gonna try
to do something,
and I have a feeling we'll
do something in the future.
But even when we were in
the little negotiations
and then things
just moved too fast,
you were basically like,
"Just gimme something,
and I'll make it work."
You didn't wanna negotiate.
You were just like, "Let's
make it nice and easy."
And then things just happened
to move along in
a different way.
But was that a
real shift for you?
How you're gonna do business?
Actually, how you're
gonna engage in that?
- Yes and no.
I think one of the
lessons I learned
was that if you're a
really good negotiator
and you negotiate a deal
where it's so great for you
and bad for other people,
that's not a good negotiation.
It just ends up in a lawsuit,
aka Steve Madden's shoes.
When Steve came to
me, he was very young.
He was naive, and I took his
company from him legally,
and I took 85% because
he didn't know better.
And all that did was created
animosity down the road.
So I don't think a
great negotiation is
when you get such a good deal
that you fuck
everyone else over.
And also, I just
refuse to cut corners.
In my life, my value
system right now,
it's based on creating
value for people.
There's a reason
why I haven't...
Everybody's "why haven't
you launched any NFTs yet?"
There's a reason why I
haven't launched NFTs,
'cause I'm not sure if
the market is ready.
I know I'll make a
quick 10 million.
But probably the
people who buy them
might lose a quick 7 million.
So I didn't do it.
Yeah, I'd love to
have the extra money,
but I have enough money.
I'm not gonna engage
in transactions or
any business practices
that I'm not giving more
value than I receive.
And frankly, I've ended
up making more money
because (chuckles) of that.
Greed shows me.
If I'm greedy,
that means do that,
give people more value,
'cause you make more
in the long run.
- When you see these insane
policies of just printing money,
and then Biden comes out, "Oh,
inflation has nothing to
do with printing money,
and it's not our fault
and blah, blah, blah,"
as a guy who
understands business,
you wanna punch
the screen or what?
- Yeah, so, Biden's an idiot.
And I think everyone knows that,
but he's a puppet.
The movie's so bad.
It's like "Dave."
- Great movie, great movie.
- Where can we find someone
so stupid and so malleable
and he's so much of a
puppet they're like,
"Ah, heh, heh,
here we go," right?
- To be clear, you're not
talking about me, Dave.
There was a movie "Dave"
with (snaps) Kline.
What's his name?
- Kevin Kline.
- Kevin Kline, thank you.
Great movie, by the way.
- Great movie. Yeah.
Biden is a total puppet.
I think everyone knows this.
He's not making any
decisions, right?
And he says stuff that...
It's idiotic.
It's patently false.
And that anyone
knows the first thing
about money and economics
and the way the world works
was like, "What?"
It's just silliness,
and I'm not quite
sure why he says it.
I would think that people
would coach him better,
- But do you think
they actually...
I've come to the
position that I believe
they fundamentally want to...
I've said, "Destroy."
- Destroy the country?
- They either
wanna fundamentally
destroy the country
or alter it in a
way that nothing
that we've known about America
will exist anymore.
And the dream that
eventually got our parents
to be middle class
in Long Island...
And we grew up, basically,
in the same exact spot,
a couple years difference.
That dream of then
us doing better,
they want to destroy that
'cause they want us
as cogs in the system.
- I'll tell ya a good
little analogy here.
My wife's Argentinian, right?
And the country was
destroyed by socialists,
by the Peronists, right?
They're called Peronistas.
The party's Peronistas, right?
My wife's family's wealthy,
and all those people are
anti-Peronista, right?
And I know there's
one of the group...
It's mostly wealthy people.
They're all on the right.
There's one guy who's a
Peronista. He's loaded.
He makes money from
the government.
- Oh, ya don't say.
(Jordan chuckles)
- His gig...
Ya get it?
- Yeah.
- He's a Peronista, but he's
making all his money by budget
and just stealing, basically,
through unions and
stuff like that.
It's just the
biggest hustle ever.
It's just a hustle.
They want that because...
It's literally
people in power...
There's so much wrong
with our system right now.
And starting with term limits
and professional politicians,
these are all things
that are just destroying
the country from the inside.
It's like a rot.
How could they pass this thing.
Everyone has to get a COVID
injection but Congress?
How would...
I don't understand.
- They also gave themselves
a raise this year
'cause they're doing
a hell of a job.
- But getting back to your
point with things he says
about money and printing money,
it's just a fact that
when you print money,
it leads to inflation.
And the worst part
is the one thing
that we have going for us
over the last 50 years,
since the '70s when Nixon
cut a deal with Saudi Arabia
stabilizing the dollar as the
global reserve currency...
Oil would only be
done in dollars
in exchange for
security guarantees to
Saudi Arabia, right?
That set the dollar firmly as
the global reserve currency,
the petrodollar, right?
They're going to China now
and pricing contracts in yuan.
And by cutting off Russia
from the banking system...
I think it was the stupidest
thing in the world.
All you're doing is
you're hastening the move
away from the dollar as the
global reserve currency.
And once that's done,
all bets are off
because we cannot print money,
if we're not the
reserve currency,
without having runaway
hyperinflation.
That's how we get away with it,
because we're the
global reserve currency.
So the rules don't apply to us.
If other countries try
to print money like that,
then the World Bank comes
in: "Ah, you're a scam."
They shut the country down.
It goes into hyperinflation.
They call in their loans.
We don't do that,
because we're a global
reserve currency.
And I think that's ending
very quick and hastening
'cause of the move with Russia.
It was a huge error.
- Is the biggest issue that
nobody really understands this?
That nobody really gets
how any-
- Oh, I think
people understand it.
- Well, I guess a
certain set of people do
but not enough of
the average person.
They hear Biden say, "Oh,
we're printing more money,"
and they're like, "Oh, well,
I guess there's more money.
(laughs) We'll all
have more money."
- I think that there's
a couple things, right?
Number one, yes, a lotta
people don't understand it,
but there's something else.
The left is really, really good
at using emotionally charged
issues to hijack the narrative.
What they do, for
example, is like...
Okay, from a fiscal perspective,
cutting Russia off
from the dollar
is the dumbest thing ever,
'cause it forces them
to go into China,
it forces them
away from dollars,
and it serves our
long-term cause,
to have the world using dollars.
But the moral justification is-
- Get them off the system.
- And that's the most important
thing is the moral part.
So the left is always on
this moral high ground.
And I said this before
in our last interview,
that the ends
justifies the means.
And I'll tell ya, if
you go back in history,
anytime countries or
societies were operating
under that paradigm of
the ends justifies means,
bad shit happened.
Bad shit happens.
When the ends justify the means,
it ends badly almost
every single time.
- Well, nothing's off the table,
'cause if it's just
about the ends,
you'll do anything.
You're gonna end up killing
an awful lotta people,
putting an awful lotta
people into poverty.
- Tell me how you can literally
take a country on purpose
from energy independence
and make it dependent
on foreign energy.
It's like, "What?"
"Because of global warming.
That's the most
important thing,"
so again, they
hijack the narrative.
That's really what's happening
is they use these things.
Morally, this is the
moral high ground.
I think the U.S. has no moral
high ground on anything.
It's a joke, ya know?
And it's so sad that I'm
actually reading Al Jazeera now.
I use Al Jazeera and BBC and
"New York Times" and Fox.
I have to read all of them,
trying to find what's...
"Could I get some
truth out of here?"
I'm reading everything
I can get my hands on.
Then trying to say, "Will
someone say something different
than everybody else," ya know?
It's scary.
- I hate to tell ya, but
the government of Qatar
is probably not giving
you the truth either.
But I get your-
- I want the opposite.
I wanna read
"TASS," for example.
I wanna see what
"TASS" is saying.
What's the other side...
I was out for dinner
with a Ukrainian
right when the invasion started,
and I'm like, "Oh,
this stuff of Nazification
is ridiculous."
He goes, "It's actually true."
He goes, "No, there
actually is Nazis."
And he is so against Putin.
He hated Putin. It
was just devastating.
He lost his business.
He goes, "Well, that part,
though, is actually true."
So the fact they're
saying there's not Nazis
and there's a whole
big Nazi issue
and there is a Nazi party-
- Literal Nazis.
- No, literally.
- People can't believe
it, because we've
so ruined the word.
- Literally are there.
There's a problem with it there.
And it's true.
And the fact that
we're denying that...
Why would we deny it?
Okay, Putin can
still be an asshole,
and that could be true.
It's more complex.
It's nuanced, right?
He still has no right to
invade a sovereign country,
but there are Nazis there,
and it is an issue.
- So the Nazis are
the good guys now.
- Yeah, of course, Dave.
- That's how stupid
they've made everyone.
- Enemy of my enemy, ya know?
- Yeah, I wanna ask
you about FU money
because you hear a
lotta people say this:
"Once you get FU money, you
can do whatever you want."
I know a lot of people
now that are very wealthy,
some with the B in front
of it, some with billions.
And I would say with the
exception of Peter Thiel,
who actually puts his
money where his mouth is
and says unpopular things,
I know a lotta rich people
that are more afraid, I think,
than the average person,
'cause you suddenly start
feeling you have more to lose.
What do ya think about that?
- I think there's different
categories of people.
There's people who are worth
over a certain amount
where they have fuck-you money,
whether that's a billion or a
100 million, wherever that is.
They have enough money.
But their businesses
are susceptible
to public shaming.
So they have to be careful
because they have a
fiduciary responsibility.
They can be canceled
by the left.
So they have to play the game.
And inside, they're
probably saying,
"This is a bunch of shit and
ridiculous nonsense," right?
But they actually
are playing the game
that they have to play
because they might be rich
but they also have
responsibilities
to shareholders and stuff.
So that's understandable because
they just have to do that.
Or else they'll
have huge issues.
Like Disney, you think this
guy from Disney really thinks
that teaching three-year-olds
and five-year-olds
about transgenderism
is a good thing.
Who could think that?
Who could possibly think
that's a good thing, right?
- He's digging his own grave,
and he doesn't even realize it.
Or maybe he does realize it.
Do he maybe does realize it?
- He's given in to the mob.
I don't understand.
Listen, you're gay, right?
- Ya know, my husband is.
- It's just that shock.
You're lucky 'cause I wish I
was gay, 'cause I like guys.
I'm just not gay.
I get along really well with
guys. That would be a gift.
I think it's a gift, by the way.
- If I could pass it on.
- I know you'd pass
it on, all right?
But here's the thing.
I have this theory, okay?
So lemme unpack for you a
little bit here, all right?
- I am but a humble listener.
- Gays were so
terribly persecuted.
Terrible shit happened
to gay people.
It was so fucked up in
England and the United States.
People would go to jail.
It was (indistinct)
committed for being...
So there was a real fucking
problem with gay people.
And a lot of people are gay.
I think it's a much larger
portion of the population
is bisexual or (indistinct).
It's a very substantial
amount of people.
It's fucked up that that had...
Shit had to change.
It had to change.
And Hollywood, which
has a large percentage,
probably higher
than the average,
for whatever reason, 'cause
it's arts or whatever...
And some very powerful people
like the Gethins of the world,
they did shit.
They had to do it,
and it was good.
And it was good. It
had to change, but-
- Wait, what do
you mean by "it."
- In other words, gays were....
You couldn't come
outta the closet.
It was up to be gay.
And I think that's
disgusting, okay?
I think it's unfair,
and I think people should
be able to be happy.
It just doesn't make to me.
I couldn't imagine not be
able to love the person I love
and marry them.
I just couldn't
imagine living that.
For you, if you
couldn't do that,
how could you live
that way, right?
But people still live that way.
That's fucked up.
So I think it's good.
That part is good.
- Oh, you mean that
there was representation.
- That it was take it out...
- Oh, I got ya.
- It was normalized.
- [Dave] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- To me, I think it's
normalized, right?
It's normalized, isn't it?
- You get an award now.
- Right, right, right.
- We're overnormalized.
- But that's the point.
But that's good,
good, good, all good.
I think it's all good.
What's not good is then
you have this other side
of transgender and all
these other things that...
And people are still entitled...
If that's what you want,
(claps) great, bravo.
Live the life you want.
But we start to talk
about very, very small,
minute percentages.
And now you're asking the world
to sing to a different tune.
So what happened was this
pendulum swung into madness.
What started off as a wonderful
thing that needed to happen
has turned into some insane,
almost a dystopian, future,
where up is down, down
is up, right is wrong,
and wrong is right.
You're seeing things like Lia
Thomas is a perfect symptom.
You look at that, and anyone...
If an alien from
outer space flew in,
it'd say, "What the fuck?
Are these people fucking crazy?"
What does Putin think of that?
Imagine what Putin's saying?
- Well, I think China's pretty
freaking happy about it.
- China, they're saying,
"What's wrong with
the United States?
Are they crazy?"
- Well, you know this thing
about how on TikTok in America,
it's all of this gender stuff
with these 15-year-olds
doing all the gender stuff.
But they ban all
of that in Chinese.
- Course they do.
- And it's Chinese company.
You think something's
going on there?
- I used to kid around:
"the decadent West,"
"the decay of society."
Well, this is the
decay of normalcy.
- Yeah, one swipe at a time.
- And I think it's very much
related to what happened
with gay people,
because that was a good
thing that had to change,
and I think it somehow swung
into this bizarre or
alternate universe.
And I think we're
living that right now.
- You know the really fucked
up part of that as a gay person
is that when all that happens,
then I see people who start
freaking out about gay people,
and I'm like, "I actually
somewhat get it," at some level,
not at the equality level
where you have to
treat everyone equally
but the fear because
you see them with...
They wanna do this...
Five-year-old kids, they
want them to be able
to talk to state teachers
and keep that private
from the parents.
But you got...
Do you admire the...
We were talking about
branding before and messaging,
like with COVID,
that they got everyone
to say, "Don't say gay,"
even though gay's
not in the bill.
Somebody there's doing
some decent messaging,
even if ya hate the message.
- Yes, but it's pretty easy
when you have the entire
news apparatus on your side
and, again, they squash
out alternative opinions.
I give DeSantis a
tremendous amount of credit
for always standing his ground.
But I think, though,
to me, at least...
I never looked at
that as being serious.
I'm like, this is just nonsense.
It's just more
idiotic woke nonsense,
and everyone knows this.
I'm assuming that you all know.
You all know this is crazy,
that to teach four-year-olds,
or first graders-
- Apparently, the Disney
employees don't know it.
- Yeah, well, that's just the
most virtue signaling bullshit
I've ever fucking seen.
It's just nonsense.
And you know how liberal I am.
I'm a fucking liberal!
It's just idiocy.
It's just fucking idiocy.
- We could use
a little more old-school
New York attitude, huh?
- How about common sense?
- [Dave] Common sense?
- Common sense.
- I don't know.
But I think...
You wonder about the righteous
wrath of black people.
And then I watched "12 Years
a Slave," and I get it.
It's always more complicated.
That's why in some...
It's almost like the
analogy is what happened
with gay people and this.
This is like the
dystopian end of the gays
where it's now not
about that anymore.
It's almost with black
people, there needed to be...
I mean, God, when you
see things like that,
you can't even believe it.
It's shocking.
Now, I'm from a liberal
family in Queens.
I didn't grow up
with no prejudice,
'cause no one was prejudiced.
It wasn't like that, right?
- Isn't it crazy to
think back on that?
It wasn't, at least
where we grew up.
New York (indistinct).
- Not at all.
- Everybody was
there, and nobody...
I have no recollection
of anything like that.
- So I remember
when I was young,
I was in (sighs) first
grade / second grade,
there was busing.
They started busing, and
there wee some riots.
I remember this very
vaguely, but in my household,
there was never the N word.
There was never any...
It was always equality, ya know?
It was just a very
liberal household,
so I didn't see any of that.
But I think there's other
parts of where I grew up,
in other parts of Queens,
where there was a
lot of animosity
over blacks being bused
in, integrating schools.
It's a very complex issue.
- Yeah, and not to say
there was nothing there.
Robert Moses purposely put
the bridges on Long Island low
so the buses
couldn't get through,
so it's not-
- There's a really
fucked up history.
And that's what I was almost
saying with the gay stuff,
that there was a real
problem needed to be solved,
but then (chuckles) it
goes into la-la land
'cause it overcorrect itself.
- Is there a business
metaphor something like that?
Where like you accomplish
your goals as a business-
- Yeah, Facebook.
Yeah, if you sort
of figure it...
You know what I mean?
The gays accomplished the
goal of equality, right?
You can get married.
You can adopt kids.
You can have kids
through surrogacy.
All of that stuff, they...
The equality, it's here,
but then ya don't stop.
There must be like a
business version of that.
- Yeah, Facebook.
- Ya just keep going,
whatever the hell the mission.
What was the mission.
- Lemme tell you what happened.
- The mission was for him
to get laid, basically.
- There's a theory
I have on this, too,
that organizations tend
to become exaggerations
of what their values are.
They exaggerate
themselves over time.
They end up becoming more
and more and more extreme
to what their core values are.
They become, like Stratton
became, more crazy.
If it's crazy, a little
crazy gets crazier,
crazier, crazier, crazier.
Woke becomes more...
It always exaggerate 'cause
there's a echo chamber
and this effect that happens
of self-reinforcement,
surrounding yourself
with like-minded people.
The ultimate echo
chamber is Facebook,
where they skew the algorithms
so you only see
what you wanna see,
what you like to hear.
So your beliefs are reinforced.
I've watched my third wife
going into the Q thing
because they fed her this
stuff on Facebook, ya know?
And I think it's
really screwed up.
When I look at Facebook,
the values of that company
are just so fucked up.
And I don't think he'd
probably started off
as a terrible guy.
- He probably
wanted to get laid.
- He wanted to get laid, right?
And then it became
this gross exaggeration
of almost an Orwellian
spoon-feeding people
what they wanna hear
and what you want them
to hear at the same time.
- Are you telling me
you're not excited
to go into the metaverse
led by humanoid robot
Mark Zuckerberg.
Are you going?
- The good thing
about the Metaverse
is it will not be led
by Mark Zuckerberg,
because by the nature
of the metaverse
and everything about blockchain,
it's a decentralizing force.
So centralized institutions,
while they'll play some role,
I believe that this next
evolution is gonna be
away from centralized
institutions.
And we see that right
now happening in
the financial world.
You have these new
platforms popping up,
like SushiSwap and PancakeSwap.
These are just names of
decentralized exchanges.
A 15-man company decentralized
can outperform Coinbase
that has 8,000 or
15,000 employees.
It's so much more
elegant and effective.
I think that over time...
I don't think the
Metaverse will be dominated
by people like Zuckerberg.
I pray it's not.
- So you're pretty...
I know this obviously,
but you're pretty bullish
on crypto and all that.
Are you surprised that
Bitcoin didn't move that much
in the last two months.
After what happened in Canada
where they were
freezing bank accounts,
you'd think that
Bitcoin woulda blown up.
And then all the Ukraine stuff
and the SWIFT system,
as you mentioned before,
you'd think that Bitcoin right
now, or crypto in general,
would all be skyrocketing,
but it's actually not quite
like that at the moment.
- The way Bitcoin...
Let's start it Bitcoin.
It's still in its infancy.
And until it matures
and really becomes
more of a currency and a
legitimate store of value,
whichever one you
wanna look at it as,
it's gonna trade mostly
like a growth stock.
It's gonna trade like a
speculative investment.
And that means
there's gonna be times
where it's risk
on and a risk off.
Right now we're in a
risk off environment.
People are doing
flights to safety.
Six months ago, it
was more risk on,
and the hot money
was going into things
like Bitcoin and Ethereum.
So that's part.
Simply, it was very
much correlated with
the stock market.
Stocks are going up;
Bitcoin's going up, right?
- Is that partly just 'cause
people have more money, then,
and they're just like, "Ah,
I'll just put more money
into Bitcoin, too, 'cause
I have more money."
- Partially, but
what's happening is
is when people are scared,
Bitcoin is still
not mature enough
that people look at it
as a flight to safety.
It's just not.
And it was supposed to be that,
and it probably will be that,
but it's still not there yet.
And Bitcoin is
still manipulated.
In other words, there's
still some very big people
that fuck with it, right?
But I think generally
speaking, right now,
what you're seeing, and I
think it's helping Bitcoin, is
you have this trading range
of 35, whatever it is,
to the high-risk 60,
and that's okay.
It takes time.
When Bitcoin crashed down
to $3,000, or $2,000,
it stayed there for a while,
and then ultimately,
it has another rally.
So I think it's building
a base right now,
and then ultimately, it will
go substantially higher.
I think this pressure's...
And again, that's just my point.
(indistinct) tell you
to buy because of that.
But I think that the nature
of Bitcoin, the scarcity,
the stickiness that
people tend to hold it
for the long term,
there's a lotta things that I
think are, over the long term,
putting upward
pressure on the price.
- What are you doing with
your money these days?
In this crazy time
that we're in-
- I am heavily
into the crypto,
de-fy, metaverse,
very much into that.
But I don't have to
invest my money so much.
It's not what I do, really.
My model is more
people will actually give
me stakes in their companies
in exchange for advice
and using my brand.
So I have very much
of a risk-free model
of getting involved
in companies.
Now, when companies that
are bigger and more...
Well, let's say the better
deals I'll put money in.
I don't mind doing that,
but very often the
more speculative deals,
they're looking for advice.
They're looking to get
connections opened up to them.
So I do a lot of that,
and I also invest in the
off-blockchain world as well.
I have a great iced tea
company that I'm involved,
which is blowing up right now.
So for me-
- You can pimp 'em out. Come on.
- Yeah, well, it's nothing new.
- You can buy the product,
and you can buy the iced
tea, which is great.
It's called Montauk Iced Tea.
- There ya go. Come on.
- And it's unbelievable.
- Come on. You're a salesman.
- Yeah, and it's amazing.
It's great iced tea.
It's all over the place in
the Northeast right now.
It'll go nationwide this
year throughout the year.
Here's what I believe.
The safest, best investment
in the world for anybody...
You want a investment tip?
Ready for this?
Buy the S&P 500
in a Vanguard
no-load mutual fund,
hold it, reinvest the dividends,
and just set it, and forget it.
And that is your
best bet of all.
- So that does show me you're
still bullish on America
to some degree, right?
- Well, listen, again,
I think that America's values
and its global positioning
and, I said, the middle
class is gonna get squeezed.
But the 500 largest
corporations,
they're running
this show anyway.
They're behind all this,
this whole
military-industrial complex.
They're in charge.
What you're doing is
when you're buying that,
you're buying the collective
ingenuity of America.
And for all our faults,
the system is amazing.
What we have here as an
economic system is powerful.
It rewards hard work.
It rewards ingenuity.
And unlike other countries,
where success is frowned on,
standing out is frowned on,
here we worship or we emulate.
We elevate people
who have taken risks
and make a lotta money.
- What would you do
if you were CEO of one
of these companies
that was going woke.
If you were the head
of Disney right now,
knowing everything
I know about you,
and now the company seems
like it's in upheaval,
and the board's angry at you,
and people are...
It's hard to gauge
how much of it's real,
but if you had a general sense
of what's going on right now,
and they're coming to you,
what would you do
different than this guy?
DeSantis smacked him down.
- I'd probably lose my job
(Dave laughs)
because I would simply...
What I would've done is I woulda
never let it get this far.
I would've been having this...
I believe the problem usually
comes way before that.
It's like this virus,
this cancer that's
forming and spreads,
and it spreads, and it's
allowed to keep spreading.
And before you know it, the
inmates are ruling the asylum.
So I would've been carefully,
or let's say almost
daily, messaging things
that were against that
whole thing, supporting...
As you know, I feel about
gay people, whatever.
But I would have a very,
very different type
of corporate culture.
But that said, the way
the world works for now,
it's almost like you'd
get canceled like that.
So it's pretty high
and mighty of me
to say I'll stick
to my core beliefs,
but I might have to be forced
for fiduciary responsibilities,
or I'd be fired as the CEO
for not pretending to be woke.
- Do you think that's the move
is that so many of these
companies probably,
even if they don't fully get it,
are maybe not taking care of
their fiduciary responsibility,
meaning they're not
making the right decision-
- Listen, listen, listen.
- For the company.
- Lemme give you
the crux of this.
You just brought up
a great point, okay?
It's the ultimate
diversion play:
"We're woke (claps).
We love the environment,
and we love gay people
and transgender,
and we're gonna
fucking destroy people
in sweat shops in Indonesia."
Literally, there's
such awfulness. Nike?
What they're doing,
these companies are exploiting
people all over the world.
They're polluting.
They're doing all
this terrible shit,
raping and pilling the village
on a fucking daily
basis pretty much,
all of them, almost
without exception
but some less than others.
But they're woke.
They're good corporate...
They're good citizens
of the world.
So it's the ultimate thing for
Apple to say that we're woke.
- They're a bad guy
in a Disney movie.
That's what I keep
telling people.
- Literally, it's that
much of a "we're woke.
W-w-we're good people, moral.
We're moral and moral."
And they just
destruction, destruction.
And the left is amazing
at that: "Watch here.
We're woke. We're woke.
That means we can spill
as much oil as we want.
We could exploit as many people
from undeveloped countries
as we want.
We could literally avoid taxes
and keep money in
different countries
and use clever
transfer mechanisms
so we don't pay our fair share
of taxes, but we're woke.
We're good. We're good."
- But they'll give
you a shelf on Hulu-
- "And we love the environment."
- That says "black lives
matter" or something.
- "Love the environment."
- Urgh, it's gross.
- And the Black
Lives Matter guys,
aren't they in jail now
on their indictment.
- What happened to
Black Lives Matter?
Did they solve-
- They were under indictment.
- It was a scam, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- So this great cause...
Of course black lives
matter. White lives matter.
Yellow lives matter.
Lives matter, right?
But these people were
just like freaking crooks.
They're under their
indictment, aren't they?
- They're under indictment.
The woman that was the
head bought three houses
in Malibu or something.
- Stop it.
Did they send one-
- Well she's got nothing
on what's her name.
Who's the one from the...
The senator from the West
Coast, Representative Maxine?
- Oh, Maxine Waters.
(Jordan giggles)
She's got a $20 million
house in Hancock Park
while she's running
Crenshaw or something.
I mean, these people.
But that's what I
always tell people.
You gotta admire the monster.
- You have to, but by the way,
they don't even touch
fucking Argentina.
They don't even touch it.
- At the level of corruption?
- Pfft, there's a
woman in Argentina,
this woman, Christina
something-or-other,
who's literally like...
She runs the whole
fucking country.
She the wealthiest
woman in the world.
She's a Putin of
Argentina, this woman,
and everyone loves her,
and she's (indistinct)
raping and pillaging.
And she's a fucking...
The kids sing to her:
"Thank you, Christina,
for the roof over our head
and the food on our table.
- Man.
- Oh yeah.
Hopefully, this will air after
I get back from Argentina,
or I'll be shot one
while I'm in Argentina.
- Yeah, you could be
in a lotta trouble in Argentina.
- No, but it's amazing
that you see this weird
undercurrent of politics.
I hate to say this, 'cause
I don't really mean it,
but there's some
part of me that...
I like Xi because at least
you know what you're getting.
You know it's completely
corrupted and no rights.
You have no rights.
Yeah, I get it. That's the play.
At least I know
the playing field.
It's almost better
than, almost, saying...
They're pretending
to be different.
- It's so twisted.
Well, no, no, I-
- You know what
I'm saying, though?
- I heard Bill Maher,
maybe a year ago,
say something like that.
They can get shit done because
they're not messing around.
There's something
admirable about that.
And here, I know, people are
gonna cut this exact part
to make us look like
we're supporting China.
But it comes at an
obvious, insane cost.
Everything that
we love about life
is the cost of them being able
to build a city real quick.
- But not what they
love about life.
I think one thing I've learned
from traveling around
the world so much
is that the world
doesn't share our values.
Many countries don't
really care that much
about free speech.
Hey, they'd like it. They
don't value it like we do.
They didn't grow up with it.
It's not part of their
core belief systems.
People in Russia love Putin.
I was there a few years back.
Everyone loves this guy.
They say, "We love
a strong leader."
- Strong leader, yeah.
- "We don't care, all right?
We just want a strong leader."
That's what they want
there, all right?
Now, they're probably having
second thoughts right now,
I'm guessing, right?
And there's a lotta-
- It's a little hard to tell,
don't you think?
We keep saying...
The meme is we've
destroyed Russia.
- I don't believe any of it.
I don't believe any
of it, by the way.
I'm not saying that we haven't,
but I don't believe any of it.
- But why aren't we seeing
videos coming out of Russia?
I don't know. Riots
in the streets?
Toppling the whatever?
- Here's the same analogy.
I was out for dinner with a
Ukrainian who hated Putin,
who was devastated
over the invasion.
He's like, "Yeah,
we have Nazis."
There's more to this whole
thing. There's issues.
Ukraine was part of Russia.
It's much more complicated
than the world's making out.
I don't know why.
Listen, again, I think it's
a terrible thing, and I wish-
- Isn't it annoying to
have to do the caveats
every time you're
talking about something,
'cause of the-
- It's really sad.
But the bottom line
is is that this is not
enough to start World War III.
And I resent when someone like
Zelenskyy, as a U.S. citizen,
says, "If you don't save
us, it's World War III."
What? I mean, what?
I don't know. I don't
want World War III.
So if we don't help,
if we don't give you
more guns and admonition,
it's World War...
I don't believe that for a
fucking second, just so ya know.
I don't believe
that for a second.
I don't think there's any
way Putin will ever go
into a NATO country.
- Yeah?
- No way. I don't think
that's gonna happen.
And by the way, I think Putin's
looking like a paper tiger
a little bit right now.
But I think also
to give a madman...
And it seems like
he's a madman, right?
I don't know. Maybe he's not.
But it seems like
he's acting that way.
You need to give a madman
an exit ramp. (chuckles)
Okay, let's say
he's a madman.
- Especially one with nukes.
- He's got 5,000 nuclear bombs.
Let's give the guy an exit ramp,
and maybe it's okay that
he takes part of Ukraine
and that becomes part of Russia
and people stop dying.
Why not think more pragmatically
than "Putin bad. Ukraine Good"?
I just don't believe that
for a fucking split second.
- Jordan, you'd have
to think for a minute
to do that.
- I know.
- What are you saying?
The people on CNN are
gonna be telling people
that they're allowed to think?
- Even the people on Fox,
with the exception of Tucker,
who finally said
what I was thinking.
I've been thinking
that the whole time.
Ask my wife.
I've been saying it to her.
She's like, "Really?"
She's like, "It's so terrible."
It is terrible. It's awful.
But there's more to this
than they're saying,
much more than they're saying.
Here's another part
to this whole thing.
When the whole world
gangs up on one thing,
then you have to know...
(Jordan laughs)
This certainty everyone else has
has to tell ya there's
something wrong.
- Isn't that the thing?
That's, I think, the thing
that's got my bell
going off about this.
I'm not saying I know exactly
what's right. And I'm with ya.
Ya can't just invade
a sovereign nation.
Okay, nobody's defending Putin.
But to watch the swarm...
Basically, every single person-
- Except China and Saudi
Arabia and the UAE.
- So is that really...
Do you feel like we're
actually in the midst of...
Biden said it just
a couple days ago:
new world order's on the way.
Odd he didn't say that
during the election.
Do you remember
him saying anything
about a new world order coming?
- This guy has done more damage
(chuckles) to the country.
It's amazing.
It's like almost a talent.
- And he doesn't even know.
- And you could destroy
something that quickly
in just two years.
You can hate Trump.
There's no way this
would've ever happened
with Trump as president,
no fucking way.
- Trump is looking pretty
freaking good right now, right?
- No way this woulda
happened, no way,
and not because Putin
thinks he's a madman.
It just wouldn't have happened,
because there was this...
And by the way, lemme just...
So, he calls Putin
a war criminal.
Well, that's helpful for...
(Dave laughs)
That's gonna make the war stop.
- Urgh.
- So now you give the guy
no chance.
He can never stop,
because if he loses,
he goes to The Hague and
gets hung at The Hague.
So now you create no
possible peace solution.
That's the fucking
arms manufacturers
moving Biden's lips:
"War, war, war,
death, death, death,
money, money, money, and
instability, instability."
It's so fucking obvious.
How could he say that?
It's almost like we said.
What a moron, ya know?
- And they keep telling us,
"We're not going
to World War III.
We're not gonna World War III,
but we're gonna arm the guy.
We're gonna talk
about a no-fly zone,
so then we'd have to
shoot down planes.
We're gonna cut them
off the banking system."
We're doing an awful lotta shit.
I dunno where you have to
sign the doc that says-
- He's begging
for a no-fly zone, fuck yeah.
- We're all agreed it's war.
- You wanna destroy my
country, too, Zelenskyy?
Really, I understand
you're in a bad spot,
but do you wanna
destroy the world?
You wanna take the whole...
That's what'll happen.
You start putting a no-fly
zone there, that's it.
They won't do it.
It won't happen.
There's no no-fly zone.
I don't care what Putin does.
It can't be that stupid
to go head to head
with someone with
5,000 nuclear bombs.
- But we've got a lotta wizards
who got us into a
lot of other wars
that are telling us a
no-fly zone'll be just fine.
Sure, they've never gotten
anything right before,
but maybe this is the one.
- The generals that
are saying that-
- Odds, ya know?
- Are just people
that are saying
'cause they wanna go on TV.
They can't possibly believe...
I forgot who it
was saying, "Yeah,
we could have this
humanitarian. no-fly zone."
Oh yeah, sure.
- The humanitarian corridor,
that's what they call it.
- That's gonna work out
really fucking well, ya know?
And I also think
that by the way...
I could go on and on about this.
I just think that arming Ukraine
is just causing more
lives to be lost.
It's just killing
more Ukrainians.
- Belfort, finish
me up with this.
The world's nutty.
Okay, everyone gets it.
We moved to Florida.
Life is good here.
You're feeling good about life.
When I do my daily
show, every day,
I'm always trying to
tell people at the end
I don't want you to get
crazy about politics.
I want you to do something
you're supposed to be doing.
Give the people
the Jordan Belfort why
everything's gonna be okay
and why you gotta
just keep going
even if you're worried that
it's not gonna be okay.
- Oh no, I think
everything's gonna be okay.
See, what happens is even
when there's a recession
and they say, "There's a 3%
contraction of the economy"...
What does that really mean?
If you made $50,000 last year,
and then suddenly your
income goes to 48,500,
you're still paying your rent,
you're cutting
back a little bit,
but to living like...
I think what
happens is is people
that are living empowered lives,
people that are
willing to work hard
and put one foot in
front of the other,
you're gonna be okay.
There's always a path
forward to make money,
to live a great
life, to be empowered
in this country, in the
United States, right?
It just makes it a
little bit harder, ha.
They just make it harder.
Instead of having a tailwind,
ya have a little
bit of a headwind.
But that's it. Ya just
pedal a little bit faster.
Listen, when I got outta jail,
I was saddled with
a very large fine.
And by law, the maximum
they could make me pay
is 25% of my income.
You know what I said to
myself when I got outta jail?
I said, "I'm not gonna
try to evade this fine.
I'm just gonna make
so much fucking money
(Dave laughs)
that the 25% won't even
be pimple on my ass."
And that was my attitude:
"I'll make so much money,
I'll just pay that,
win-win for everybody."
- How quick did
you knock it out?
- Well, no, I still pay, but-
- Oh, you're still-
- But there's no one getting...
No, there's no more
investors left.
Investors, there's
no more investors.
Investors haven't gotten
money for 10 years.
Another two years, I
gotta pay this as some...
(slaps) It's ridiculous, okay?
But the point is I never
tried to look at that
as "well, then I'll just
either stop working,
or I'll try not to pay."
No, I'll just work even harder.
So if the world
gets a bit tougher,
if politicians like Biden
create a playing field
that's tilted against you,
just pedal a little bit faster.
It's worth it because
you know what?
We live once, right?
And where you are
in your life...
You can't control
what happens randomly,
but you are the master.
You're running your ship.
You're the master
of your own destiny.
You have the ability.
I don't care who you are.
As long as you're
healthy, you're breathing,
you can improve
your lot in life.
If you want,
every human being
has the ability
to get ahead in this country.
If you're somewhere else...
In some countries,
it's difficult,
but even there, you
can always get ahead.
And I think that all
of this stuff is noise.
It's disturbing. You
can worry about it.
Yes, you can worry about it.
But to think for a second
that it will stop you
from living an empowered life,
that's a story that you
tell yourself as an excuse
because you're not willing
to do what it takes
to get what you want in life.
I firmly believe that,
that it's a story
that you tell yourself
that "argh, it's the
government. It's the economy.
It's my parents. It's the news."
It's all story, and once
you stop with that story
and learn what
you have to learn,
go out there and do
what you gotta do,
you can get ahead in this world.
- So do we start a company now?
Or do we drink tequila?
- I think we drink tequila.
(Dave wheezes)
(Jordan giggles)
(Dave claps)
- Jordan Belfort,
ladies and gentlemen.
If you're looking
for more honest and
thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles, instead
of nonstop yelling,
check out our
lifestyle playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full
episode playlist.
They're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.